I have to upload it with you
means definition
decision
and the decided
English I
already liked it
Okay
difference Because you know the
problems Like languages
Like in history
found only language that had a
non-Luluna parlato but but but
most of the time Practically only a
rare Italian but  He is an Italian with
a high polyglot because he participated
calmly Defines such Because
I think that
YouTube in any baby
and things has changed not even the
Italian tuba has already said
no practically in love with the language
possible
Ok pineapple
and
tell me
what school they have attended
Okay okay
more  yours bilingual gives
interpreter of translators the
linguistic miniature
that he knows that the second of the study
that fails
beginning
the queues illicit appearance
perfect it
But perfect it
and perfect the technique to be
an interpreter And you what type of study
was not a great that
air
Okay okay
al  world of language
in a single There was always a passion but
when I studied language
true
life
in Venezuela short your product to
school interpreter you object to the
songs
philosophy
is a
very interesting animals indicator for we fulmos a little in
Portuguese
I have a conversation
or Portuguese
a  problem
Portugal continental Portuguese plus the
majority of people
a Portuguese Portugal a little more a
little too signed and what a
beautiful Portuguese and above all a Brazil a
very very important country now
and I want to know your history
and that's why
determined and here continental like me
some say that I
queiro with a sotakira
Portuguese Portuguese Portuguese I
always say in Spanish for example a
Portuguese
and Portuguese Portuguese
better problems
on YouTube
in video on YouTube
Yes because now now we are going to change in
Spanish because what happened for example
with us is precisely that you  You
know me because
you watched some YouTube videos and then
you knew that since we are friends on Facebook
or I don't remember what
happened but you knew that I was in
Oslo and that's why you sent me a
message and told me you are in  What are
you doing in Oslo we can
see each other and then we have seen each other
not in the center of Oslo the station do
you remember no
And then well I know what happened
because well I was there But can you
tell me let's tell together what
happenedin
oslo with catering not for people who
don't know who Katherine is Katherine is
another one is another She is one she is a
fantastic girl I always say I I have
found her I spoke with her twice I
found her in Paris and also in Oslo of
course and well
she  She invited us to her house in what
is the name of Stabec which is a city which is
a city 5 minutes from Oslo And what
happened do you remember we
had a blast yes
that same day no yes yes because she
had invited me but I didn't know that  You
will arrive too and then I told her well
the phone told her another
friend is arriving and she is an extremely
open person and she is fantastic I always say that
and she said well nothing happens she can come
too and
we ate at her house with her daughters
who
That's what I wanted to say is that
what surprised me a lot is that,
for example, he has two
teenage girls, one is 12 years old and speaks
English like a [ __ ], not with an almost
native accent. That's why I imagined he
was already thinking about Italy.  a
12 year old girl who speaks I don't know English so
so so perfect it's incredible no but I
was wondering if it's a
peculiarity or if all the girls or
all the 14 15 year old boys speak
English so so fluently in Norway
because because  well
the level the high level of What is
the high level of knowledge of
English here in Norway is it
also comes from
the American influence that there is not in the
country that is very strong
I think that good And that has
increased over time  No, well,
when I had one, when I was 12
years old, of
course there was a lot of influence,
but not as much as now, I don't know
much,
and it was a lot. Yes, if not, I think
it's incredible, it's incredible because it's like
having almost two native languages ​​and
They, of course, are very curious to
know what they had done to reach
such a level. Menu level and I asked them
and they already answered me that at
first what they do is watch
a lot of television, not in American, in
American English, especially because they
both  They have an American accent They don't have an
English accent Can you explain to me why
For example Norway is not that
far from England But how is it that
almost everyone in Europe I mean I don't
talk about everything about all the countries in
Europe but I talk in general about many
Northern European countries, for example,
in Holland, the typical accent is
the American accent, which is this
Central American story. Because many people
ask me, for example, why, because
we think it is normal.
No, I have always thought that it is normal
to speak American English.  but a lot of people
ask me, for example, the land,
people looked at me askance a little bit, what are they
saying to me, they were wondering
why that guy, they thought he was
American, but that's not necessarily
a positive thing in some countries, not
like the Spanish accent is spoken.  with
a traditional accent in many countries in
South America, that is, I don't know because from
direct experience I don't know because I have
never been in I don't know in Latin America
in general but I know because I spoke with
many people with a lot of South Americans
who always asked me why  You chose
Spanish that was so traditional and that he didn't like
what your experience is. For example, you
speak you speak Spanish more from
South America, not because your mother is this
Cuba, so well,
since I grew up in Norway, I don't know, it
mixed a little with the other sauces
of course.  there Not clear
enough
is that he is a Spaniard Well South American
of course but you have never been in Spain
no
never
but you speak with Spaniards
but you I mean you have to be honest that
no one is going to kill you but for example
you like the traditional accent you
find it  a little a little hard I don't know
because the general idea is that the Spanish
of Spain is a little more I don't know it has been
spoken much faster quickly and I don't know
why I speak this this version and for
me it is the same but for many people that is not  I mean, he does
n't like it, I don't know why you
could, maybe I don't know, you know better
than me because you don't like it or if you like it,
of course it depends on the person and
many South Americans who
like the traditional accent but  To others, the
majority, at least my experience
from my point of view, does not like it,
wait, then you, okay, okay,
one of the purest, for me, you
know the Latin, they say gusty bus,
arguing is not, I mean, you can't
argue.  About tastes, I mean, I
always say that, for example, I
like all accents, but there
are also many people who like one
and don't like another. It's a matter of
taste for me. As I always say, the most
important thing is to talk.  the language later well
nothing happens if you don't like the
accent they are going to get used to it I am going to get
used to an accent that I don't like
but it is a question of I don't know you have to
be open No you are super open
so Of course of course Okay
then of course
So
we had this talk in I think six
languages ​​and I wanted to ask you now
always in Spanish what you are going to do what you
are going to study now you know 6 languages
Now you have one It is evident that you have
a passion
and that you know that languages ​​are
incredible tools for  change your
life and then I was wondering if I do
n't know do you want to learn another language for
example I don't know Chinese or
other languages ​​like Africans I don't know Tell me
tell me a little bit about what you want to do
now
Chinese not just not just for being a
good language that
well with a lot of global strength now
of course Emerging economy of the country
but
already making quiet the
moment of turning Yes from exploring
another another world Of course of course because
learning another language is having another soul
no what they say
is what it is
no  and I am very interested in how a language is, it
is not at all similar to the ones that I already speak,
of course, because
you know, many people say, for example, that
if you already know many languages, learning I don't
know another language is easy, but what
I think is that it depends on the language.
You already know, for example, Spanish, French
and Italian, learning Portuguese is not
a problem but if you speak 10 languages
that are similar and then you have to
learn another language, for example
Japanese, which has nothing to do with it, or
maybe Chinese.  to other other
Asian languages ​​Well that can be a
problem you know I mean it doesn't necessarily have to be a
problem but those
very different languages ​​you know a lot of
people say for example they don't learn
Chinese They don't dare because it is too
difficult the problem is not that much  It may not be
difficult but it is very different because
if you look at the grammar of Chinese for example,
the grammar is not a problem if
for example you have to say I want to
go to the United States it is very similar
to the structure and the syntax is very
important but of course  They have a
different mentality, that's why
you have to say many things
in a certain way if you want
other Chinese people to understand you, you know
that's the main problem,
but in general I think that learning
Chinese, as you say, is opening the doors
to another world, you're going to  totally change not
your idea of ​​seeing the world no It's not just about
speaking it's just about speaking
languages ​​no but it's about changing your
mentality and now now you live in San
Miguel I
'm not almost in the middle of the Atlantic
Ok
and But you want to go to another country  now or do you
want to stay there for a while a while a
time
to perfect the language not the
Portuguese
the two languages ​​I want to learn
well number one Chinese and number two
Russian also because Well I like it a lot because
because I have always liked Russian
pop music  that's the the the the the the the the the
push of the
always because what I like to
say is that for example they say
many people say that for example in those
podcasts are the videos we always talk
about languages ​​in a certain way it's true
But  I live my life through
languages ​​but I have many interests,
the reason why, for example, I have
reached a certain level in the
languages ​​that I have is because I like the
world. So, as you are saying, you
don't like it, not only  If you like
languages, if you don't like it, I like it a
lot. History, philosophy, mathematics,
cinema, music. So through these
things, looking, if you want to explore these
worlds, then you're going to learn the language. It's
not that I learn languages
to speak with others.  to enjoy
culture is not my That is my goal
is what I want to do languages ​​for
me are tools I think that for
you it is the same more or less
interests do not go through languages ​​And it
goes There is a  Independence No
that is that it is expensive and James Aurora
concluded in Italian that the language of
our communication